have you ever been speed-dating uh what
does that mean so you just like speed
date like a different guy you know yeah
yeah you do like every like five minutes
it's awful don't do it I'll tell you
about it sounds like a junket but for
dating for men but we're gonna speed day
I'm gonna speed-date you right now I'm
just gonna do
[Music]
who have you been the most starstruck by
Helen Mirren and I threw up in forever
sighs it's a luxury oh my god wait to
hear this story
who do you idolize the most my mom what
is the best piece of career advice that
your mom is giving you work hard love we
do stay humble wear sunscreen who who's
the one band or singer you can listen to
no matter what mood you're in drink
drink
[Music]
we know favorite candy sour patch kids
salty or sweet salty I don't know why
I'm half screaming biggest deal breaker
in a man if you're not funny like get
out of my face what is your ideal date
this right here yes biggest but also
that there was multiple soup here and
like like a cream soda
soup and soda what is it that's like
some sixties like Oh sexy all I want is
limited Amy to get some soup and soda
many therapists
[Music]
you